Amber Rose breaks her silence over Kanye  West's controversial famous video  amber speaks out on the rapper's music  video that featured her completely naked  in bed with eleven other celebrities why  I made that [ __ ] famous 32 year old  model talks her rise to fame as Kanye's  girlfriend telling The Daily Beast that  she wants to be recognized for her own  accomplishments and says there is a  gendered double standard I'm sick of  that everything I've done since then is  my own doing Wendy Williams put  Charlamagne on jay-z put Kanye on but  they don't do that to men and they  always want to diminish my  accomplishments and put them on someone  else when I work really hard  the reporter continued with more  questions about Amber's ex and their  past Amber fired back saying quote I'm  not talking about Kanye at all I'm not  going there